[Music]
what is the biggest scar on jamaica
because of the united kingdom i mean the
whole idea of jamaica is the scar right
the royal african company which is
founded by the monarch was the one
company that enslaved more africans than
any other company in the entire world
and the monarchy cannot be separated
from slavery at all
from the darkest days
of our past
and the appalling atrocity of slavery
which forever stains our history
[Music]
as a descendant of slaves i'm aware of
the very difficult and troubled history
[Music]
fewer people think that there will be a
monarchy in the next hundred years what
do you say to that i get to count the
millions of people
out on the streets this week
i'm going to count the millions of
people at the jubilee
so i see no sign
of the monarchy being in trouble but
it's got to prove itself to every
generation
[Music]
people are really suffering financially
at the moment and suddenly we have 11
days of non-movement because of
tradition do you think king charles
could ever be as loved and admired as
queen elizabeth no
no we don't know no what would you say
to a critic who says the uk does not
need the monarchy anymore oh
i would completely disagree
because it brings tourists in and we
welcome people and we want people to
come and see our history